lehrjahre sind keine Herrenjahre ohne
Fleiß kein Preis wir haben noch hart
gearbeitet für unser Geld
okay Boomer kennt ihr solche Sprüche
auch viele jüngere Menschen haben das
Gefühl dass die
älteren Menschen in Deutschland den Ton
angeben und das schon sehr lang fast 30
Prozent der Menschen in Deutschland sind
älter als 60 Jahre denn dann steigend
und noch nie seit Beginn der Zeitreihe
gab es so wenige junge Menschen zwischen
15 und 24 Jahren jetzt gefühlt ist
Deutschland eine richtige
rentner-republik Klimakrise
Verkehrskollaps verschlafene
Digitalisierung Schulen 1.0 Inflation
Staatsschulden wer soll die Suppe
auslöffeln naja die alten regieren das
Land entscheiden über Dinge die sie gar
nicht mehr miterleben werden und
verbauen jungen Menschen damit die
Zukunft stimmt das denn ist unsere
Demokratie für junge Menschen ungerecht
in diesem Video hier gibt's die
Antworten
[Musik]
wenn Politikerinnen und Politiker in
Deutschland versuchen junge Menschen
anzusprechen dann kann das schnell mal
unangenehm Grinch werden irgendwie
hapert es bei der Kommunikation oder
doch nicht ich habe die Wohnung in einen
tiktok-star verkauft und jetzt müssen
wir hier alles mal ausmessen weil genau
hier muss nämlich der Whirlpool hin 23
bubatz legal man kann die versuche
natürlich belächeln man kann es
Politikern und Politikerinnen aber auch
anrechnen wenn sie zumindest versuchen
junge Menschen zu erreichen auch wenn
das für beide Seiten manchmal noch
ungewohnt scheint schauen wir mal ein
paar Jahrzehnte zurück auf die
Bundestagswahl im Jahr 1980 die
Verteilung der Wahlberechtigten war
damals wie in Bilderbuch die meisten
Menschen waren zwischen 30 und 60 und
der Anteil jüngerer und älterer Menschen
war relativ ähnlich seitdem hat sich die
Demografie in Deutschland aber ziemlich
heftig verschoben Menschen werden immer
älter eigentlich gut das Problem ist nur
gleichzeitig werden viel weniger Kinder
geboren als noch vor einigen Jahrzehnten
der Altersdurchschnitt geht also
ordentlich nach
und es gibt deutlich mehr ältere
Wahlberechtigte als Junge bei der
Bundestagswahl 2021 waren etwa 14% der
Wähler unter 30 dagegen waren fast 58
Prozent also mehr als die Hälfte der
Wählerinnen und Wähler 50 Jahre und
älter die Älteren haben also viel mehr
Einfluss zumindest an der Wahlurne dazu
kommt die Wahlbeteiligung bei den
älteren ist deutlich stärker als bei den
Jungen vielleicht auch weil sich junge
Menschen oft nicht von den Programmen
der Parteien angesprochen fühlen das
wäre zumindest eine Vermutung außerdem
haben junge Menschen offenbar das Gefühl
auch Meinungsforscher hätten sie nicht
auf dem Schirm hier beim Politbarometer
to go schauen wir ja auch immer mal
wieder auf Umfragewerte und welches
Stimmungsbild ist in der Bevölkerung zur
aktuellen Politik gibt wie das ausfällt
in den Kommentaren schreibt er uns da
manchmal das doch eh nur alte Leute
befragt werden und dass ihr selbst noch
nie angerufen worden seid aber genau
darauf achten die Meinungsforscher der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen und damit ihre
Umfragen repräsentativ sind passen sie
ihre Methodik selbstverständlich an die
Befragten werden zum Beispiel auch auf
dem Handy angerufen mit zufällig
generierten Nummern die Handynummern
generieren wir nach dem reinen
Zufallsprinzip es wird einfach ein
Zahlen generiert und ein automatischer
weltcomputer
versucht die hier Verbindung dann
herzustellen wenn das nicht zum Ergebnis
führt dann wird die nächste Nummer so ja
die genau das gesamte Auswahlverfahren
funktioniert das haben wir euch schon
mal in einem anderen Video erklärt das
findet ihr wenn ihr oben auf das eklig
auch unten ist es noch mal verlinkt die
Meinungsforschung hat sich jedenfalls
angepasst und unsere Demokratie zurück
zu unserer Rentner Republik die
zahlenmäßig mächtigste Zielgruppe für
eine Partei sind also ältere z.B die
sogenannten Babyboomer die
geburtenstarken Jahrgänge der
Nachkriegszeit die Babyboomer sind die
Generation die in Sachen Bildung
Wohlstand und lebensfreiheit ihre eigene
Elterngeneration abgehängt hat okay
Boomer während ihr die Rente genießt ich
übertreibe mal gleich zum Beispiel die
Generation Z also sind die ungefähr
zwischen 1997 und 2012 geboren sind
gerade erst ins Arbeitsleben ein die
Digital Natives denen Nachhaltigkeit
Work-Life Balance und vociness wichtig
sind also mal ganz allgemein gesagt
Babyboomer gegen Generation Z das klingt
nach einem harten generationenkampf die
analogen Überflieger vs die digitalen
gesellschaftskritikern okay gut damals
natürlich ebenso ziemlich alle Klischees
ausgepackt die so gibt warum nicht alle
junge Menschen links grün versiffte
vocal Hipster sind das haben wir schon
mal in einem anderen Video erklärt
findet ihr oben auf dem i und natürlich
gibt es auch nicht nur Boomer und
Generation Set sondern auch andere
Altersgruppen die Lebensweisen der
Generationen unterscheiden sich nun mal
teilweise ziemlich deutlich und dadurch
eben oft auch die politischen
Vorstellungen das ist auch ganz gut so
weil wohl jede Generation ihren eigenen
Weg finden will das Wahlergebnis der
älteren hat insgesamt mehr Gewicht weil
sie eben mehr sind so richtig fair
scheint dass wir junge Menschen nicht zu
sein andererseits repräsentiert das
Parlament am Ende eben den Willen der
Mehrheit der Gesellschaft die nun mal
alt ist also funktioniert Demokratie
oder was denkt ihr schreibt gerne unten
in die Kommentare wie sehr sind
politische Entscheidungen der älteren
Wähler überhaupt an ihren eigenen
Interessen ausgerichtet sehen Sie
einfach total ihre ego-nummer durch nach
dem Motto noch ein paar Jahre und dann
nach mir die Sintflut wohl eher nicht
eine Studie der Bertelsmann Stiftung hat
das vor ein paar Jahren mal untersucht
und da war das Ergebnis sogar eher dass
viele ältere Menschen
zukunftsorientierter wählen als junge
Menschen und klar die jungen Menschen
sind ja auch die Kinder und Enkel der
alten natürlich sind sie ihnen also
nicht ganz egal mal ganz allgemein
formuliert das sieht man ja zum Beispiel
auch an Fridays for future da sind vor
allem junge Menschen dabei die Bewegung
hat aber auch viele ältere
Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer es
gibt ganz viele Untergruppen der Fridays
for future nur Generation Greta ist da
ein bisschen zu einfach und bleiben wir
noch mal kurz beim Thema Klima jüngere
Menschen schätzen die Klimakrise
allgemein als ein dringendes Problem ein
als ältere wir gehen häufiger für den
Klimaschutz auf die Straße und richten
ihre Wahlentscheidung öfter nach diesem
Thema aus wie auch bei der
Bundestagswahl 2021 aber vielleicht sind
die Anschauungen doch gar nicht so weit
auseinander wie viele denken spannend
dazu ist eine Umfrage aus Hamburg 2019
kleiner disclaimer Die beruht auf
Selbstauskunft und Selbsteinschätzung
trotzdem auch wenn jüngere in der
Klimakrise das größere Problem sehen
sind es vor allem ältere die bereit sind
dafür Opfer zu bringen
57% der über 60-Jährigen versuchen
beispielsweise Flüge zu vermeiden bei
den 18 bis 39-Jährigen geben das nur 32%
an ähnlich ist es bei der Vermeidung von
Einwegverpackungen oder dem Kauf
regionaler Lebensmittel das deckt sich
auch mit der Studie junge Deutsche von
Simone 2021 da kam heraus dass
ökologische Nachhaltigkeit jungen
Menschen wichtig ist aber dass sie den
Einsatz dafür im Alltag auch
mehrheitlich vernachlässigen ja scheint
wohl doch keine Generation perfekt die
wirklich ticken älteren jüngere Menschen
also wirklich gibt es Themen bei denen
die Einstellungen weiter auseinander
liegen oder doch eng zusammen es gibt
ganz logisch von den Erfahrungswerten
von den Lebensumständen von den
Bereichen indem man sich betätigt
kulturell soziale Art logischerweise
immer Unterschiede zwischen den
Generationen aber wenn wir mal ein paar
Jahrzehnte zurückgehen das miteinander
vergleichen dann hatten wir früher viel
viel größere auch kulturelle
Unterschiede zwischen den einzelnen
Generationen in Deutschland denken Sie
zum Beispiel an die Abholzeit wo es auch
zu handfesten Auseinandersetzung
zwischen verschiedenen Generationen
gekommen ist was könnte man tun für mehr
Gerechtigkeit bei der Wahl macht und
eine zukunftsorientierte Politik damit
vieles überlegt z.B ein generelles
Wahlrecht ab 16 Jahren steht auch im
Koalitionsvertrag weniger ernsthaft
diskutiert wird z.B die Idee Senioren
aber eine bestimmten Alter das Wahlrecht
zu entziehen das wäre klar
verfassungswidrig habt ihr noch Ideen
braucht es überhaupt Ideen um etwas zu
verändern ich glaube allerdings dass es
eine Sache gibt die vielleicht nicht nur
Spaß machen könnte sondern die zum auch
Jugendliche in den politischen Diskurs
bringt und schlussendlich auch
gesellschaftlich und weiterbringt
nämlich
debattierkurse in den USA beispielsweise
ist das ja riesig sowas würde Spaß
machen man würde sehen hey junge Leute
können argumentieren was ja können nur
alte Leute ältere Menschen würden das
dann vermutlich auch sehen und sagen hey
ja das ist eine richtig gute Argumente
ihr habt ja wirklich was drauf was
natürlich junge Leute ohnehin schon
haben es würde Spaß machen man würde
gegeneinander antreten es ist eine Art
Wettkampf und es würde eben den
gesellschaftlichen Diskurs voranbringen
weil wir auch in Deutschland lernen
würden mehr lernen würden miteinander zu
diskutieren und nicht nur aneinander zu
kritisieren
als Jugendlicher hatte ich exakt das
Problem dass ihr jetzt habt der
Unterschied wir waren damals deutlich
mehr als ihr Stichwort Babyboomer
gerannt Generation und trotzdem hatten
wir keine Stimme außer auf der Straße
zum Beispiel und hinzu kommt dass die
Unterschiede zwischen euch und meiner
Generation heute deutlich geringer sind
als die zwischen uns und unseren Eltern
damals also ich habe überhaupt kein
Problem euch die zugestehen zu stehende
Stimme zuzugestehen denn genau das ist
ja Demokratie aber ich habe ein problem
wenn jemand sie mir beispielsweise
wegnehmen will weil ich alt bin im
Grunde wollen wir dieselbe Richtung
Demokratie mit größerer Fairness und
Gerechtigkeit der Feind sind also nicht
die alten sind auch nicht die Jungen der
Feind das sind die Gegner der Demokratie
und eine ungleiche Verteilung von Macht
im politischen System Stichwort
Lobbyismus ich würde mich also sehr
freuen wenn wir gemeinsam weiter in
Richtung der Demokratie laufen also ganz
klar sollte geworden sein als oder jung
das muss nicht immer zum
generationenkonfliktiert werden es gibt
nicht mal große Unterschiede es gibt
aber auch große Gemeinsamkeiten im
Grunde liegt für mich die Lösung ja auf
der Hand wer etwas bewegen will der kann
sich einbringen ob in Vereinen
Initiativen Gesprächsrunden was auch
immer und das Politik immer ein
altherrenclub sein muss diese
Vorstellung ist zum Glück in vielen
Teilen überholt nicht erst seit den
klimaprotesten wissen wir dass es genug
Menschen außerhalb dieses Kreises gibt
die etwas bewegen wollen Beispiel
parteimitgliedschaften bei der FDP und
der Linkspartei sind junge Bürger 2021
zum ersten Mal überrepräsentiert und in
eine Partei einzutreten ist tatsächlich
eine von vielen Möglichkeiten eigene
Ideen einzubringen wichtig ist und
bleibt aber vor allem wählen gehen egal
ob alt oder jung seit 1953 liegt die
Wahlbeteiligung der jüngsten
Wählergruppe hinter der der ältesten
zurück und ich finde es ist ein hohes
und extrem wichtiges Gut für die
Demokratie dass jede Stimme gleich viel
zählt ob alt oder jung egal welches
Geschlecht oder welche Herkunft habt ihr
vielleicht noch einen Vorschlag wie
junge Menschen mehr nutzen könnten oder
muss das gar nicht sein sagt ja nee die
alten können das ruhig auch machen
irgendwann sind wir alt dann kümmern wir
uns darum schreibt es gerne unten in die
Kommentare und mehr Infos zum Thema und
noch mehr Zahlen und Daten findet ihr
wie immer in der Infobox in unserer
Reihe Politbarometer to go haben wir uns
auch schon mal mit Generationen
beschäftigt und mit Generationen
Klischees und mit der Frage ob alle
Jugendlichen links grüne Hipster sind
etwas vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen
die Antwort darauf findet ihr hier in
diesem Video und in dem Video darunter
da haben wir zusammen mit frontal
angeschaut was der demografische Wandel
eigentlich für unsere Rentensystem
bedeutet einfach hier klicken danke fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal